I know from genetics, I have a problem making glutathione.
Any problems you see with demilized glutathione?
No, not at all.
So we talked about that three weeks ago on the Zoom.
We see a lot of autoimmune patients in our office.
We saw people in the office back early 2000s and such.
After I wrote my book on autoimmune disease.
And it was.
And we did demilized glutathione and everybody.
So that was prior to the esacetyl glutathione coming out.
So understand there's several forms of glutathione out there.
And they progressed in their.
In their quality over the years.
So in the late 19, you know, 90s to early 2000s.
There was a form of glutathione that wasn't really well absorbed at all.
And in taking it, you know, was kind of beautiful.
So, uh, nebulizing it worked pretty well.
So we used that form in a nebulized form.
Or we just dissolved it in fluid,
either water or fluid or silver.
And then debilized it.
And people would just stay there.
And then debilizer and breathe that in for 10 to 15 minutes.
Very beneficial.
Then they came out the esacetyl glutathione.
And the esacetyl glutathione is much better absorbed.
And that was a huge hit in the natural community.
Because you could actually absorb glutathione.
I understand glutathione is recycled in yourself.
And it's through the system pathways.
And from a genetic standpoint that that function takes place.
Um, then, and just about five years ago or so,
and they came out with like a zonal glutathione.
Holy cow, total game change, you're there.
So like a zonal glutathione is even, you know, 10 times better absorbed.
Um, and remember, glutathione is your number one antioxidant.
And remember, what does an antioxidant do?
The antioxidant helps get rid of oxidizing agents.
If you don't get rid of oxidizing agents, you're dead tomorrow, period.
Oxidizing agents are poison.
Oxidizing agents are your number one cause of cancer, period.
So we talk about, oh, toxins are what toxins are number one cause of cancer because they're oxidizing agents.
So oxidizing agents damage cell membranes kill cells who sell through lysis.
Uh, damage DNA, you're better off but kill, kill the cell.
Um, cause the damage is DNA and it causes cancer.
So you have to get rid of oxidizing agents and glutathione is your number one way to do that.
Interest cell.
We have different pathways and phase one, phase two pathways that you do sell in your liver,
even though glutathione's in your liver, glutathione, it's a cellular, you know,
that's why it's elevated in your tissues is your number one way to do that.
And you need to recycle it, you need to support that recycling.
And if you have defects on that, it's even more difficult.
So taking liposomal glutathione is great.
Second best thing would be to have your life.